hello guys we are here in Austin for
South by Southwest and I am so thankful
for Commissario tequila because because
of those wonderful sponsors that we have
on the table right here we get to talk
about movies like the wall of Mexico
thank you guys so much for your time
today first off because a lot of our
viewers don't know what the wall of
Mexico is and I can already see and
understand why people might make certain
assumptions about a movie with that
title would you mind briefly explaining
what the movie is about and who you play
in it I mean in reference to the title
the wall of Mexico it's more than just a
wall and it's more than just the wall of
Mexico its walls of all kinds borders
and boundaries that separate us from one
another male and female generational
cultural and they're trying to just turn
a lot of the expectations on their head
with what people are thinking they're
gonna see when they see this movie so
that they'll become more mmm you know
mentally and emotionally involved in the
subject matter it's definitely a complex
film but I mean that's at its root the
plot is essentially about a wealthy
mexican-american family who have this
artesian well on their property that
they harvest and they sell to people
could be magical water could be magical
water there's a lot of superstition
involved in this film and when the the
well water starts dropping rapidly and
they assume someone's stealing it they
hire a couple of white groundskeepers
well they heard me 35 years ago but it
hired me a week ago to build a wall
around their property essentially
keeping out the poor white townsfolk so
we kind of take the narrative of the
border wall and kind of flip it on its
head a little bit and I mean we filmed
this a little over a year ago and it's
even more the wall of Mexico I mean just
hearing those terms you know and these
guys are so smart that in addition to
the water being slightly magical which
is what makes everybody want it it's
also again I saw it for the second time
last night and I got so much more out of
it even the second time around that you
realize oh wait a minute the water
the American Dream and that's why
they're all craving and it may not be
real and so they're just it's all kinds
of different things going on and yet the
characters are all very real and very
engaging the the two daughters of the
wealthy Mexican landowner happened to be
incredibly decadent and extremely well
educated and so it's all these very
interesting things so Don and then it's
an incredibly visual movie they've done
things with it that I've never seen
before it's amazing stunning to say the
least the cinematography here really is
exceptional but to go back to something
you guys were kind of touching on a
little it's not necessarily a movie that
spells everything out for you and I
enjoy a challenge like that but just
jumping into these roles were there any
specific questions that you went to the
directors with that you kind of needed
answers to to get into this headspace I
don't know for for me playing Don he's
kind of the everyman kind of an open
vessel so I didn't really want things
explained as much I wanted to just kind
of have this experience of curiosity in
wonderment and the idea of I remember
going just to the sets level of the the
play room of the these young hedonist
daughters like a playroom that they had
together and just being just looking
around and being like wow and then
thinking to myself I don't want to do
this right now I need to go away and
then wait for the cameras to roll to
really kind of just be enthralled and
really kind of look around the room and
see what I'm seeing and they spent so
much time developing the look of this
film and our cinematographer Lynn
Moncrief was just a phenomenal guy to
work with obviously you see some of the
most beautiful shots in the film are
composed by him and in our in our
directors and it was just here's a
stunning thing to watch and back to the
characters though well you were an
everyman of sorts upon which we get to
project a lot of our own experience
coming into this world for the first
time I took the role I was actually
through Jax and gotten ahold of me right
before they started shooting so
I was flying in trying to put everything
together with the story and let the
character as I got down there to Mexico
where we shot just cool and his this
guy's supposed to been there for 35
years but the water is magical in a way
keeping everybody younger so they young
to be up for this movie a little bit
which they never do I'm about to go play
really old next week and the the Mike
character is the foreman on the property
that's hiring and bringing this guy in
is a trickster you can't tell what side
he's on you can't tell what his agenda
is whether he's right left up down and
it was a super fun character to play the
sort of coyote archetype a really big
ensemble you two obviously have a
connection but there's there's a lot of
connections and chemistry with mostly
ensemble around you as well so I was
wondering what is it like working with
the different actors did anybody have a
different process that surprised you or
maybe somebody that brought something
out of you that you didn't expect well I
think our directors had a much different
process than is normal I would say in my
living you know the man here percent of
the films that I've done you know we
would take like a what like a two-minute
scene and run it for eight minutes and
just kind of go back and forth almost
like I said some terms I would I would
almost want to say it was like almost
like a Meisner technique of getting
different line readings and getting
different like vocalizations or trying
new things which I rather enjoyed it was
kind of the the experience it was
antithetical to it with to a theater
experience where you have this kind of
performance very fluid which sometimes
would punch in on these ideas and be
like okay let's try it again like this
let's try this let's let's like maybe
flip the scene completely on its head
and it was it was really fun to be kind
of sitting especially for my character
it really worked because this is a guy
who's really curious it's kind of
constantly confounded and he doesn't
really have a set of ideals yet he's
young enough and he wants this beauty
but he doesn't understand it so he
doesn't completely want it he wants to
be a part of something
doesn't know what that's something is
you see those wheels in his head turning
from the start of the film to yeah I
hope so I like I want him to be I want
it down to be this guy that you kind of
feel for you kind of think is maybe a
little dumb but not in like a like a
hick dumb way but just just the idea
that this is a simple guy with simple
desires and you just wants to you know
eat me getting back to their process so
let's get back to that keep steering you
back to the questions my mind the the
thing to I think is it's interesting to
having worked with a million directors
to see how different suddenly still a
new approach is that really kind of
brought us all under the same page
because I think everybody was thrown off
of their usual moorings by this approach
because he's a poet and a writer and an
English professor Zak before becoming a
filmmaker and so he approached things
they spent two years almost two years
visualizing and making all the decisions
before we arrived so that they would
have you know they went through the
conflict between the two of them they're
a male-female partnership which is
fascinating in and of itself and so they
went through the conflict so that there
wouldn't be any unset which doesn't
necessarily work out that way but for
the most part we kind of went along but
it was a very very precise very specific
it was almost as though it was scored in
his head and he was gonna nudge
everybody into that vision of his and
their story which she meant she managed
the visual aspect and he managed the
acting and I think a typical direction
would be like even when you thought you
were doing total minimalism that's great
yeah maybe eighty percent less and
really cool I love being I loved the
encouragement to become more minimalist
especially with a comedy where it
because it's a dark art comedy but to go
under everything instead of over it was
really
it's interesting to hear you describe
their process like that cuz I was
reading an interview with the two of
them and even though they weren't
specifically talking about how they
worked on set I could just tell that
they had they just specified very
specific ideas and kind of knew exactly
how they wanted to execute everything or
at least that was just the sense I got
from reading a black and white interview
we were entering their world and
becoming a part of it and it was fun I
think that's what really you see the
chemistry on on camera with everybody it
was you know a lot of naturalism and you
know Xander and I have worked together
many years and I begged him to come do
this movie with us and he said yes for
some reason I don't know why and I like
everybody say and I we've never gotten
to work together so that was fun and
Mariel and I had never gone to work
together and then these these gals I
didn't know but man did they do a
spectacular job and they were on the
film before anybody as the they found
the sisters first so they had their
whole language going and I think in a
lot of ways we we came in and worked
ourselves into the world around them
that's interesting that they cast them
first before we have to close this out I
have a little bit of a game for you we
call it colliders random questions
they're just like fun harmless questions
that everyone out there is dying to know
the answers to and given our
conversation before I'm especially
excited to get your take on some of
these first off what TV show would you
most want a guest star on now it is
especially there's so many and I think
you're always feeling like oh my god I
haven't seen that I haven't seen that
haven't seen that you know we're both
dads that's my favorite and then I hear
another one I'm like no that's the right
choice so you tell us which ones we
should be on yeah that's very two of my
favorite answers that I've heard
recently are killing even Handmaid's
Tale if I had my choice I would go back
in time and find a spot on Nikita
because I was a little obsessed with
that show okay can we cast her in
everything she's done and isn't she with
Kiefer my other acting partner from 24 I
thought it was so funny when they put
the two of them together spy world
unites she was so good
I loved it
y'all go back and play Percy again
that's what I'll do dammit I have more
than me you know I I'm a huge ricky
gervais fan so anything that he's ever
done I would love to go and be a part of
it
like I'm watching afterlife now and I
gotta say there's some sweetness to it
some it's very simple as a show and I
think I like that I like what he can do
as a writer and an artist what line of
movie dialogue do you guys quote the
most often well now that I'm living in
Maine I find myself saying you can't get
there from here which was a Fred Wynn
line from some movie apparently but
growing up I never knew what it was from
but my dad would always say what we have
here is a failure to communicate yeah
and then from the Paul Newman oh my god
which one is it Cool Hand Luke hey Cool
Hand Luke man I remember when I finally
saw that movement I saw that I was like
oh damn dad's the warden yeah Joe Pesci
gets a lot of quoting everywhere you go
you just sort of I think it's the most
quoted actor oh wow yeah I would say him
and then my go-to is Sam Jackson and
there's a million things that you can
quote but everybody out there Collider
knows - hold on to your butt's there you
go all right what is the worst job
you've ever had I worked at a I don't
like a brick and Brack shop does that
make sense so it's a weird term
basically it's like a like a like a
little shop with like little trinkets
like some jewelry some soap some things
like that I worked there for two weeks
when I was about 14 it was a my a friend
of Mines mother's shop and it was so
boring I no one ever came in I think I'd
like to people came in the two weeks
that I worked there so I would sit there
and I would read books and take naps
which was great I would just read so
that was nice but a bad job I I would I
worked as a janitor at my own high
school during the summer and I planned
trees and I redid carpets and I I and
that was fun I actually enjoyed that was
much harder work I'd rather be active
and doing something difficult than being
bored I'd failed hey every summer from
the time I was 12 until I was 17 so that
was a pretty brutal job but I also
enjoyed it because of the just being
outside and being you know challenged
constantly to beat my best you know how
many 75 pound bales I could get off a
field in the course of a day and unload
into the different people's barns at
night but I think super forests in
Orlando Florida was the worst job I ever
had
terrible terrible TV show that I did me
he's just you I think that some of the I
know what I'm doing tonight Xander
Berkeley super force you're gonna be my
next quote what do you guys collect
collect I still got all my baseball
cards
I collect guitars it's a really
expensive collection and I don't do it
as much in the last since I've had kids
so but you know after actually unloaded
a few because just traveling around so
much but I've got an old 57 Gibson
hollow body that's just what it was like
when I first made money as an actor and
when I was able to afford my own
apartment and and a car and insurance I
drove about insurance for two years
because he couldn't afford it and then
when I finally was able to afford all
those things and then I had some
leftover money I yeah I went out to this
really rare guitar shop and I got my
first piece and it's just it's it's I
love the the craftsmanship when it comes
to wood making and these Luthi A's and
what they can do with with with wood and
it becomes this incredible vibrant
instrument
I got a 1932 Martin that's it was like
right there at the start of the New Deal
and suddenly like you're coming out of
the Great Depression and there's there's
like hope in the guitar you can feel it
when you're holding it one person made
it and they had hammer and the frets and
so when I hold that guitar and I look at
it and I play it I just I feel a sense
of hope you collect corks
like these are all mine I drank all
these bottles of wine so we could have
this dude you got a dip here car
collector yeah they're all Prosecco
corks that people would believe last
question for you guys and this is the
one I'm very curious to get your take on
what is the most exciting thing you see
happening in the film industry right now
well on a personal level I've moved to
Maine with my wife and daughters so that
I don't have to leave to go away to work
and I'm in the process of developing two
different properties beside let me live
on in to film locations and and what I
find the most exciting to write and
direct and produce there and bring all
my friends to beautiful Maine to work on
projects at both on our properties and
around the environment because it's so
beautiful and so mysterious and and
magical and and I think that the
direction of the of the industry is that
you can I'm also gonna because now
collecting film equipment so that I can
make my own films and develop my own
content have my friends all the
participants in the the pieces that we
create together so that we can then sell
it to the various Netflix and the
Amazons and the others of this world to
get it out there into the world with
them I think you know jumping on on that
point I you know the most exciting thing
right now is we're getting original
creative diverse storytelling out there
because of streaming services I am a I'm
a movie nerd I love going to cinema I
love going to see Roma and send them up
at the same time without someone like
Netflix putting the money out there in
in you would never see a film like Roma
anymore because you know we're having
this conversation about Spielberg
constantly and what he's saying with the
Academy and I would I would wish that
someone like Spielberg with as much
money that he's made over the years
would support independent filmmaking and
I think with someone like him this is a
dangerous route to go on but I'm on a
limb here he's going to make ready
player one great movie he's a great
filmmaker but that's has a huge IP
that's not an original creative voice
he's going to what make West Side Story
an accident
that's a huge IP that's not an original
creative voice why doesn't he prop up
these young independent filmmakers
especially some from a diverse
background you think about what Coppola
said now must have been 20 years ago
said the future of film there's some
girl in your garage in Ohio and it's
going to be made so that and I'm going
to be that girl in this in her garage
and oh ha in maine in the fields on the
barns and the by the river but I bet
anyone it's it's become possible for
anyone to make a film and film festivals
having sprung up everywhere in the in
the wake of great film festivals like
South by Southwest are making it
possible for them to get seen and then
have a little springboard upon which
they can get go viral with if they're
good enough and you look at people like
Bo Burnham I mean you started off as a
YouTube sensation and his film 8th grade
was phenomenal it was incendiary and
like he I mean here it is about an 8th
grade girl
yeah and I'm watching it with my wife
and I relate so much to the character I
relate so much to the film and she and I
my wife and I just had like a two-hour
conversation about the movie afterwards
about our own experiences in middle
school about how beautiful the film was
how incredible it was that a first-time
director a youtuber you know and it's I
think you know nowadays there's such an
amazing ability for creatives to put it
their work out there I will be great if
some of these big studios were to
support them and to take risks like they
used to no kidding I mean I realized I
grew up in the Golden Age of independent
filmmaking when five to six million
dollars was a typical budget for an
independent film and now a movie is
either a hundred and ninety million
dollars or it's five hundred thousand
dollars and it's just absurd they've got
to start supporting these films so that
yes we can make them on a shoestring but
they're gonna be in playing at a Theatre
and competing with something that is a
you know a trillion times more money
invested into it and I think it really
would be great if some of these
companies that do profit looked and
picked a dozen filmmakers to support the
following year just to see and seed and
get new growth happening with
spielberg if you want the movie theaters
that have the big films invest in the
filmmakers that are telling amazing
originals really going after spielberg
ear and disorder people that make I mean
I I love Marvel too stupid I really do I
love watching the big superhero movies
but I also want a platform for eighth
grade I want a platform for Romo I like
AI and then to to knock them down
because they're on a streaming service
that that to me is it's a little
antithetical to an artist you know I
could go on and on about this topic the
guys behind the camera know it and I am
being rushed off this set thank you for
sharing your thoughts on that and also
for sharing the wall of Mexico with our
viewers guys go see their eye out for it
another thank you to our wonderful
sponsors for making these interviews
happen we will be back real soon with
more South by Southwest interviews I'm
just going to take this see you later
you